these acts and threats of violence are
not associated with any one set of
partisan or ideological views
but they are permeating so many parts of
our national
life attorney general merrick garland
saying give him
some patience as he continues uh his
prosecutions about january 6th and the
capitol rioters getting pressure from
the left
columnist jennifer rubin who one time
was in the from the right uh what what
mayor garland should say about january 6
patience is wearing thin with garland
not because he has so far failed to
indict trump or his cronies his
credibility and the credibility of the
department are at risk because he has
not yet demonstrated the vision and
nerve to defend democracy in its hour of
need now glenn greenwald greenwald uh
tweeted this a full year after the 1-6
riot at the capitol the total number of
indictments from the biden doj for
insurrection sedition or treason is the
same number as americans indicted by
mueller for criminally conspiring with
russia over the 2016 election
zero
back with the panel
guy what about this
well january 6th was an outrageous
attack on the rule of law among other
things
and i think in response to that attack
there needs to be an adherence to the
rule of law and that sometimes takes
a period of time it's not instant
justice instant gratification the way
that some people want i understand that
it's a year later there have been
hundreds of arrests there also has to be
due process for the people who were
arrested they did not lose their rights
or were not stripped of their rights
just because they behaved terribly and
outrageously and this is the way that
the process tends to go and i think that
sometimes you see politicians in this
case a political figure like the
attorney general trying to
sort of quiet some of the critics and
say hey we're still moving this ball
down the field here bear with me
and in this case i think that's a
relatively prudent and fair thing for
him to say
meantime democrats are trying to tie
january 6 again and again
to voting rights take a listen
that is why voting reform and the
freedom to vote act is so important to
our democracy
january 6 was not an isolated event it
is beyond distasteful for some of our
colleagues to ham-fistedly invoke the
january 6th anniversary
to advance these aims their first draft
of the legislation at hand was
introduced in january of 2019.
byron
well the thing they want to do right now
is kill the filibuster and they'll use
any argument that is at hand and uh two
years ago long before uh january 6 they
had other arguments to want to get rid
of the filibuster now they're saying
january 6th on as far as merrick garland
is concerned i said earlier that joe
biden was pleading for time on on covid
well garland is pleading for time on uh
on the january 6 investigations because
uh he he came out today and said look
just because we've leveled a relatively
limited indictment against uh figure a
or figure b that doesn't mean we're not
going to indict them again with
something bigger just wait please we'll
take care of it he's under a lot of
pressure
from democrats leslie
i would agree with uh both guys on this
you got to be patient you have over 14
000 hours of videotape you have 700
people arrested approximately half of
those are guilty approximately half of
those have been sentenced already but
you have a lot of people out there they
say approximately a thousand assaults
and could be up to 2500 people that will
be arrested at the end of the day and
also the attorney general said quote
actions taken thus far will not be our
last so i believe he will take this as
far as it needs to be and that means
perhaps sitting congressional members or
even perhaps a former president
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else